No,
it's a very old picture.
It's Jonah emerging from the whale.
It's a variant of a myth.
The Myth is the dragon myth.
I suppose the Dragon Myth is that
there's a dragon that lives under the
ground that's eternal and now and then
it rises out of the ground to threaten
the state and someone within the state
determines to go confront the dragon
voluntarily and does so and then brings
back something of great value.
Sometimes if the hero is generally male,
sometimes the thing of great value is a
female that the dragon has kidnapped.
That's a St George Story and sometimes
it's gold and other treasured like in
the story of the Hobbit and
story that you all know very well.
It's a classic hero story and the Hero's
story is another fundamental element of
the clinical theories.
I would say it's predicated on the idea
that you learn through voluntary contact
with that that frightens or disgusts
you,
and now it's a hallmark of
psychoanalytic theory.
Young Carl young who will discuss in
detail said his primary dictum was in
steer Colinas invented tour,
which I'm sure I massacring because it's
Latin,
but it meant infill.
That will be found and one of the
hallmarks of the clinical theories is
that within the confines of everyone's
experience and you can think about this
as experience out in the world or
experience in the unconscious mind,
there are dirty little secrets let's
say,
and skeletons and
dreadful old fears and remnants of abuse
and memories of pathological behavior
and failures of courage that you leave
you undeveloped perhaps out of avoidance
and that the psychoanalytic process is
precisely the careful encounter with
those forgotten and and repressed
elements of the self in the hope that a
clear encounter will redeem them,
unite them with the remainder of your
personality and make you make you
stronger in consequence,
and I would say that that's just a
variant of the manner in which human
beings learn,
and we'll talk about this more in
relationship to piaget because you
always learn when you're wrong,
which is very annoying.
Now,
what do you learn when you're correct
you,
you're walking in the world,
you're operating in the world,
you have a sense of what you want to
have happen.
You're always looking at the world
through this sense of what you want to
have happen.
You're acting so that what you want to
have happen will happen,
and when it happens,
well then you're happy because,
well,
first of all,
you get what you want and that's good.
Maybe depending on what you want,
but it's also good because if you get
what you want when you act,
then it turns out that your model of how
to act is valid right now.
Outcome that you get what you want
indicates no error on the part of your
model,
but it's very frequently the case that
when you act to get what you want,
you don't get what you want and then
that's unpleasant because you don't get
what you want,
but it's even more unpleasant because it
brings with it the hint of a suggestion
that the manner in which you're
construing the world is incorrect at
some indeterminant level.
So for example,
if you tell a party,
tell a joke at a party,
you presume that people will attend,
and then when they hear the joke,
they will laugh and then if you tell the
joke and it goes flat or even worse,
disgusts and offends people,
then you're going to be taken aback.
And that's partly because you didn't get
what you want and that's not so good,
but it's.
But it's more because there's something
wrong with the way you conceptualize the
situation.
And then you're faced with a problem.
And the problem is the emergence of a
domain of the unknown.
It's like,
well,
what kind of mistake did you make?
Maybe you're not as funny as you think
you are.
Not.
That can be a big problem.
Um,
maybe you're not around people that who
are the way you think they are.
Maybe they don't like you as much as you
thought they liked you.
I mean the,
the potential for various paranoid
thoughts of increasing severity to come
welling up at you in a situation where
you make a,
even a trivial social mistake is quite
broad.
And when you make an error of that sort,
you have to face it and sort through all
the possibilities so that you can find
out what it was that you did wrong and
how to retool it so that in the future
you don't make the same mistake and that
requires well,
that requires in some sense what you
might describe as a journey into the
belly of the beast.
The beast being that place where things
have fallen apart and where you're
overwhelmed with negative emotion and
chaos and confusion.
And now it's a very old story.
That's the story of the journey to the
underworld and the hero is the person
who makes the voluntary journey to the
underworld to collect what's been
languishing down there.
And that's the basic motif of
psychoanalytic theory.
I would say it's the basic motif in some
sense of clinical practice because one
of the things that you do as a clinician
is find out what people are afraid of
and what they're avoiding and that can
be in their past or in their present or
in their future.
Break it down into smaller pieces and
help them devise strategies of approach
and mastery,
and that improves the quality of their
personality and helps develop them into
people who won't make the same mistakes
over and over again.